why do you have athletic Souls on your
wingtips
you know wing tip shoes I don't know
what it is I'm gonna take these off now
these are beautiful wingtip shoes and
then at the bottom they just have a
little like a rubber grip yeah in case a
pickup game of hoop you just can take
off this tie all right well you never
know you never know what you're at all
someone would pick you on the team all
right
I is this does this look absurd to all
of you oh wait thank you sir thank you
for for leaping to my defense that whole
group over there still thinks it looks
stupid I think I think he did too he
just wants to be your friend there was
too much of emotion you think this looks
stupid he's like no
it's like it didn't require that level
we're talking about souls that should be
getting yourself nah it's fine that's
that's where it should have been well
anyway
Gold Toe socks
I'm a banker what are you a sitcom dad
in the 50s
honey I'm home hello I got a new I got a
new company car
listen oh it's great to be white
say that every morning when I wake up
that's all white people do yeah you know
that non-white people you know the
government gives us free gold-toed socks
once a month
so much for being white they just
[ __ ] hand them out
remember us from election time there
have been times when those socks got me
through some really rough periods one of
the Samson's in my way makes you feel
successful it does actually I feel good
about these shoes when your wife makes a
good point do you take off your shoes
and point to your socks
just be like do you think every guy
walks around with these
gold on his toes that's how I win
arguments with my wife you think that's
that's what I'm down to
point to something you're wearing that
you're proud of to win an argument with
you I get along great with my wife now I
just basically I just I I don't die on
every Hill no I just go all right you
know even if it makes no [ __ ] sense
to me I just think like you know what
it's it's just gonna be an argument I'm
gonna I'm gonna give in
and then we're gonna do this dumb [ __ ]
anyway so why not just act like I want
to do it you know and it keeps the peace
I slowly die inside but as we're doing
it I don't need you to act like you care
you know what I I don't really I know so
yeah yeah you sounded like you're
watching a rescue dog commercial
you want one no no I work too much
sit well I'm sure your wife is always
right too just you know no no she is
right A lot of the time yeah she is see
how that works very nice
yes you disagree with them do you talk
like this you're an ear grin have you
done have you done uh couples counseling
have you ever done that no because
somebody you can't talk this way and you
can talk this way to your therapist but
you can't sit there with your wife and
say look I just pretend what she's
saying which is [ __ ] crazy makes
sense and a little part of me dies
inside let's all go get cookies you know
you can't no you can't do that because
then you make that person laugh and then
as much as they fight it they're on your
side I know what you're talking about
you've done that yeah yeah I've never
gone to couples therapy somebody told me
like that's everybody he knew that went
to couples therapy immediately got
divorced afterwards no that's not true
well I didn't I'm just repeating what
somebody else said
that's not true
I just think we need you think I said
the world was flat sorry well until I
see real evidence uh
it is it's like a cereal bowl evidently
we're looking looking down into it great
have you talked to someone who believes
the Earth is flat
uh do you know what you would say to
them would they be swayed by pictures
from space or does that not mean
anything to someone who believes it's
all done in a studio man they do it open
burping
um no uh what would I would depend on
the situation right if it was at night
and we were by ourselves and I didn't
know him and he just approached me then
I'd be I would just be oh yeah
you know what yeah I think you're right
I would just agree with them and make
them leave
they probably wouldn't he probably his
eyebrows would go up in excitement that
he found somebody else that agreed with
his way of seeing the world right and
then I couldn't get rid of him
um I don't know it's quite a conundrum
that you came with this person for the
rest of your life they'd be a good
friend well what was bad was when I got
into conspiracy theory about the banks
and the Federal Reserve was you met so
few of those and then those other people
with with there they just thought
because you believed that those guys
were a problem that you then thought the
world was flat and all this other stuff
it's like no I don't I don't think that
I just think this stuff over there and
then they would look at you like you
were a sellout like there was there
seemed to be like no middle ground with
conspiracy theory you had to be all in
with shape shifters and lizard people
it's just like no I'm just saying the
Federal Reserve it's you know right you
thought you were saying you think in
some ways our economic system might be a
little game a Ponzi scheme yeah and a
lot of people agree with you and and
they thought well because that's a
conspiracy theory you're in on
everything yeah that I thought we didn't
land on the Moon Yeah and stuff like
that so then I you know
yeah he's calling the eyebrow raised
people because then they come up too
like you know what else you know what
else